oui merci myard écouter après mes
collègues de châteaurenard avec qui nous
avons travaillé et toi même avec qui
nous avons regardé un petit peu qu'elle
était aujourd'hui le pivot essentiel de
cette loi du 5 mars 2007 qui est le
maire un chef d'orchestre en charge
d'une politique de prévention et de
sécurité
enfin souvenons-nous 2007 de nombreuses
communes des communes la plupart de
droite qui ont souhaité mettre en place
ce dispositif et cette méthode
et quand ça a commencé à marcher et à
prendre et bien souvenons nous que le
gouvernement de françois hollande a mis
en place des concepts tels que les zones
de sécurité prioritaire ou encore à
marseille des groupes de profs
prévention et de sécurité venant
complexifier systématiquement partout ça
commençait à prendre ce partenariat
indispensable en matière de sécurité
prévention voulant détricoter cette loi
du 5 mars 2007 qui est une bonne loi qui
est une loi qui est véritablement
empreinte de réalité de vision et c'est
pour ça que je serai très brève mais je
remercie effectivement de m'avoir
combien cette table ronde pourquoi parce
qu'on va se dire mais dans une ville
comme marseille
comment on travaille autour du maire la
prévention de la délinquance
eh bien ça a été très bien dit le champ
de la tranquillité publique est
considéré par nos concitoyens comme
ayant été abandonnées par les
institutions et le champ de la
tranquillité publique c'est du quotidien
c'est ce que vivent nos concitoyens bien
souvent tu l'a rappelé il ne s'agit pas
de ce que nous faisons des grandes
réunions publiques et bien d' enjeu de
sécurité publique mais véritablement de
ce à quoi ils ont été confrontés la
veille le matin et bien là cette loi du
5 mars 2007 elle nous a véritablement
permis d'avancer à marseille en mettant
non seulement une méthode à la fois avec
des engagements que vous connaissez sur
l'espace public vous l'avez bien
rappeler un renfort de sa police
municipale dans l'exigence de mission de
service public aujourd'hui est telle
qu'il faut effectivement lui donner les
moyens et à la fois de se défendre et
d'apporter la sécurité à nos concitoyens
et tu l'a très bien rappelé nous à
marseille aujourd'hui c'est l'armement
nous iront beaucoup plus loin
avec la dotation de go pro certes il ya
effectivement une attente très forte des
policiers municipaux et c'est pas
christian estrosi qu'il connaît bien
la commission des polices municipales
qui dira le contraire
mais pour autant soyons crédibles comme
nous l'avons toujours été dans notre
politique de sécurité parce que nous
marchons sur nos deux jambes à la fois
la prévention mais aussi la valeur
pédagogique de la sanction dont je
disais soyons crédibles lorsque nous
voulons augmenter le pouvoir de
réparation ou de transaction du maire de
transactions pénales
eh bien nous savons que nous allons
rester sous certaines contraintes mais
elles sont nobles s'est construite à la
fois d'une protection juridique national
européenne mais également en laissant au
maire toujours ce pouvoir
transactionnels sur pénal sur ce que
l'on peut appeler aujourd'hui
l'infraction de faible gravité si vous
le permettez où j'y mettrai à la fois
des contraventions et des délits mais
j'y mettrai également dans cette
transaction pénale qui doit être
renforcée sous l'égide du maire et bien
toutes ces infractions du quotidien qui
sont dans le code de l'urbanisme qui
sont vous savez nous sommes tous
confrontés aujourd'hui assez à ce manque
de respect de l'espace public et surtout
qui génère de la part de nos administrés
un sentiment d'impunité parce qu'il n'y
a pas de réponse parce qu'il n'y a pas
une réponse rapide et c'est ce qu'ils
attendent au quotidien enfin le sujet
des polices municipales et bien c'est un
sujet que nous n'avons jamais laissé de
côté bien au contraire bono c'est avec
avec nous que le policier municipal à
vue à la fois son champ de compétence
s'améliorer évolué au fil de l'évolution
de notre société
je pense que nous pouvons aller plus
loin tu parles et bernard de contrôle
d'identité contrôles d'identité je sais
que c'est un vrai pan sur lequel nous
devons travailler pour mettre permettre
à nos policiers municipaux de faire du
contrôle d'identité mais attention
toujours dans un cadre juridique qui
permette effectivement de ne pas avoir
de recours comme nous les connaissons
aujourd'hui
avec la police nationale et c'est pour
ça que tous ces moyens modernes dont
ceux dont les mères doter leur police
municipale sont essentiels pour avoir
une réponse en cas de mise en difficulté
dans le cadre de ses missions des
policiers municipaux
enfin j'essaie d'aller vite mais sur la
cellule de citoyenneté tranquillité
publique
alors je me souviens très bien marseille
lorsque nous avons fait voter par une
délibération du conseil municipal la
mise en place de cette cellule autant
vous dire la surprise qui a été celle de
nombreux de nombreux élus de
l'opposition pour pour pas dire tout ce
que nous avons entendu et bien cette
cellule de citoyenneté tranquillité
publique
vous allez en entendre parler parce que
c'est un vrai cadre légal dont elle a
besoin aujourd'hui pourquoi un cadre
légal parce que c'est peut-être le seul
lieu procédurales dont le maire peut
disposer pour effectivement réa soir
cette autorité indispensable souvent on
nous le dit on se les maires nous disent
des deux petites communes enfin toews a
pas été le cas mais d'autres on se sent
un petit peu démunis avec que cette loi
du 5 mars 2007
or la cellule de citoyenneté
tranquillité publique
un exemple très concret nous recevons
sur marseille à peu près une centaine de
dossiers d'absentéisme scolaire de
dégradation et puis sortons de cette
terminologie d'incivilité ce sont des
infractions ce sont des actes de
délinquance de la proximité du quotidien
et qui empoisonnent la vie de nos
concitoyens et même à marseille
croyez moi c'est ce qui ressort c'est ce
qui ressort notamment de la part des
plus vulnérables les jeunes
nos seniors qui ne supportent plus que
les infractions de faible gravité qui
dégradent leur environnement et leur
cadre de vie n'est pas une réponse
pénale rapide et bien construisons ce
cadre procédural pour le maire notamment
appelons-la la cellule de citoyenneté
tranquillité publique ça convient ça
correspond véritablement à ce que nous
sommes dans notre esprit prévention
répression pédagogie de la sanction et
puis allons beaucoup plus loin comme
nous l'avons souhaité à marseille parce
que lorsque l'on parle de terrorisme de
radicalisation bien sachez que lorsque
vous
évoquer devant la cellule une famille
avec un mineur parfois âgés de 12 13 ans
absentéistes léger ou fugueur et bien
vous décelez déjà les premières les
premiers signaux de désocialisation sur
lesquels nous devons être très attentifs
parce que c'est là que commence le
terreau de la délinquance et il n'y a
pas de petite délinquance et le maire
est véritablement celui qui a le pouvoir
de proximité et le pouvoir d'
accompagner cette politique au premier
chef parce qu'il est le plus près du
territoire au plus près de son quartier
alors voilà exactement ce à quoi nous
avons pensé avec bernard châteaurenard
marseille
ce sont deux villes qui sont peut-être
incomparable de par la taille et la
population mais ce sont deux villes où
le maire fait passer un message très
clair il ne doit pas y avoir de petites
infractions sans qu'il y ait une réponse
adaptée et ceci c'est également une
façon de réa soir l'autorité du maire et
de l'élu et des responsables politiques
que nous sommes merci caroline